- Well let's get the show though y'all.
I'm so excited. We love
when this guest comes by.
I personally do. Not only,
is he arguably the most
successful solo musical act in history,
proven by stats, he is
also a man of the people.
He's just so cool and down to earth.
If you haven't seen one of his shows live,
shame on you.
(laughter)
It's been a minute. You've
had time to see shows.
You need to fix that like right now.
But if you have seen him live,
you know why I'm obsessed with him.
He is the ultimate
performer, in a big arena or
a small venue, both ways.
But either way you are in
luck because he has a new
Vegas residency at
Caesars Palace Colosseum
starting today.
(applause)
You gotta see it. It's called
"Garth Brooks Plus One."
Everyone give it up for Garth Brooks.
(applause)
(upbeat music)
(cheering)
- Very sweet.
- They got me. They got me.
Did you see me pull up, turn around?
I go, "Garth Brooks." (Kelly laughs)
I was like "Nope." (Kelly laughs)
- Nope. Come in there.
- I did not know you came from there.
- First time we ever did your
show, we came from there.
- We did. I know.
- We did. I about fell on
my ass down the stairs.
- I think someone definitely
told- I about ran out
of breath the whole time
cause it's- That's a big song.
Would you like to have a seat?
- It was good.
- Or we can stand the whole time?
- I'll sit when you sit.
(both laugh)
- Or we could stand the whole time.
You're a gentleman. I like it. I like it.
You look so handsome.
- You're very sweet. Thank you.
(cheering)
Can I explain the hat or not the hat?
- Oh you can.
- Can I? Yes, cause I
always wear a hat, ball cap.
I was going to wear a ball
cap, probably a Circle G cap.
- I think I've seen you
all ways so I didn't even-
it didn't even cross my mind.
- No you've got a youngin' named Tara here
that does hair.
- Yeah.
- And she really worked on my hair, right?
- Because I don't have any
hair. - It's really great.
- So she really worked on it and I said,
"If I wear ball- She goes
'You wear a ball cap,
I'll kill ya."
(both laugh)
- You comin- You look all
dapper. I like this look.
- Thank you very much.
(applause)
- I think I've seen you
all different ways so
it didn't even cross my
mind. Cowboy hat, ball cap.
Cause last time we saw
each other, I think you-
Were you wearing a ball
cap? I think in the studio.
- Yep. - Yeah. Anyway, I
wanna get to this though cause
this is the coolest hosting
thing I've ever seen happen.
So you and Dolly, ACM
Awards. Y'all just hosted the
ACM Awards together. That is incredible.
(cheering)
I mean I've kinda-
I was thinking back in my
memory banks and I don't know
if I've ever really seen
y'all do something together.
- Never have. I was scared to death.
- What. Which is crazy to me.
- It's crazy. She's all
of four foot eleven and
she looks like she's
eight foot tall when you
meet her, right.
- Oh I love- yeah I love her.
- And that picture- you
just showed the picture.
I feel I need to explain that picture.
The very first photo
we took together, she-
Would you stand up with me, sorry? - Yes.
- The very first photo she put together.
She turns like this and
then she grabs both of
my hands and tells me to place them here.
- Oh you're going to prom?
- Oh.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
That wasn't what I was thinking.
So I- She goes, "You can place them here,"
I said, "No I can't," and
then we started laughing.
And that was the shot that they used.
- Well, I don't know if you've noticed but
there's a little difference
with me and Dolly.
So my mind didn't go there.
(both laugh)
God didn't bless this.
(Garth laughs)
Blessed so much, you know.
So wait, so Dolly has said
that when you're together,
you're the more serious one. Do you agree?
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah? - She's so cool. They
were up there and they go,
"Okay we're going to photos, right."
And photos aren't boom, boom.
Now photos are just
boom, boom, boom, boom.
And I swear to God man once
they go "Okay here goes."
Boom. Boom. Boom. (chuckles). Boom. Ha.
(kelly laughs and claps)
You know that kind of thing, right.
And I'm like Holy (bleep).
What am I going to do, right?
And so when go "Okay,
photos here we go." Boom.
Boom. Boom.
(Kelly laughs)
Boom. That's all it was. All
it was just chins for days.
It was like "Ugh this is
horrible." She's fabulous.
- You just described
me and Blake Shelton at
The Voice photo shoot.
I am literally like,
"What will get me out of here?"
And I'm like, "Oh my god. Ha. Ha. Ha. Ha."
I'm like the whole time everyone-
And he literally, in
every photo, was like,
hands in pockets, like very Oklahoma.
It's amazing. But she is
very nonchalant though,
I will say being around
her, like in environments,
like working environments. She calms you.
She's like a very calming
spirit. I like that about her.
- Yeah well I mean she's
a leader. A born leader.
- Such a little leader. Yeah.
- She is- It's- I guess
when they say it's how big
is your heart. She's
taller than I am for sure.
She's- She's an amazing person.
And think about this, okay.
Every single you know
from Dolly, every single.
- Yeah.
- She wrote.
- I know.
- That's impossible, first of all.
(applause) - And the fact
that they're fabulous songs.
- And some of those are classics that will
stand the test of time.
- There is no- I'm not
sure there is any greater
country song. Once it
gets to a certain level,
he stopped loving her
today. All those songs are
kinda in that same category. - Yeah.
- Jolene. And to have Jolene
this woman talking about,
"You're going to take my man," and
you look like Dolly Parton.
- Yeah. Like what did she look like?
- Right? Exactly. So the- the- the
tenderness or the fragileness
she shows in there and when
she's sings it you believe it?
- Yeah. A story teller.
- That's- She's unbelievable and-
- That's what great though.
That's why I hadn't-
Y'all hadn't done this- Y'all hadn't done
anything together which
struck me cause you're both
incredible story tellers.
Like that's why I was like,
"I can't believe this is the first time-"
But what a way to come
out, the first time y'all
do something, host something
together. That's incredible.
- She was very sweet. I
remember when I got the call,
I'm going like, " I'm
talking to Dolly Parton."
I just couldn't believe
cause I'm such a fan.
- What? (laughs)
- And the thing is, we always
talk about the GOAT. - Yeah.
- And the GOAT is always a guy.
- Oh I get that.
- I'm not sure that the
GOAT of country music
isn't a female.
- Yeah. I like to hear it.
(applause)
- She's amazing.
Well and I guess it's
subjective too because like
when people think of
the GOAT it's probably
subjective like who in
your mind like really
stands out and holds that crown, right?
- Right.
- Like so I would say
like, "You are the GOAT for
many people." Also your
wife might be the GOAT
for many people.
(applause) - My wife is the GOAT.
(applause)
I think she's amazing.
- I know. I am- You know
my obsession with Trisha.
What's up everybody? So
Garth Brooks just announced
new shows in 2024 for his
Plus One Vegas residency
at the Colosseum at Caesars
Palace. Here's a little
something to get y'all ready.
(rock music)
- Welcome to Vegas Garth.
Register now through May
25th at 5 PM Pacific Time
at Ticketmaster.com/Garthvegas
for all purchases
beginning May 31st. Citi
card members and waitlisted
verified fans that didn't
get tickets during the last
on sale will now have the
opportunity to purchase
tickets beginning Tuesday, May 30th.
All right, lets head back
to the studio to talk more
with Garth about his life and music.
(applause)
Welcome back everybody.
Tonight's a big night.
So you kick off your Plus
One residency in Las Vegas
and now it's been extended to 2024, right?
So that incredible.
(applause)
I have said this before and I've said it
without you here. Your
Vegas thing that you did,
was so special and intense
and cool and it was
one of- It literally is my favorite show
I've ever seen. Ever.
- Thank you.
- Like you and Annie
Lennox, these are these-
They were so intimate.
They were so perfect.
But you're doing it a
little differently, right?
- Yeah. You're bringing the
band but still low-key, right?
- And you're brushing over
the most important part.
We came and did your show
before the first on sale.
- I know.
- For the 2023 shows.
- Yes.
- Cause of your show, it
went on sale on a Monday
and 2023 sold out on a Monday.
- (scoffs) Okay. - Thank you.
- Not because of my show.
(applause) - Very very much.
Yes. Thank you. And trust me-
- I think it might have
to do with you're you but
I'll take it.
- Why Caesars made me book
this again make sure you
book Kelly again.
(Kelly laughs)
- They're like go back.
So wait, why did you want
to go back to Vegas? Did you just love it?
- Yeah we did the comeback tour and we did
the stadium tour and I think the only way
you get bigger than a stadium is just
strip it down one-on-one.
- Yeah. I love it though.
You're a fan of music
how I'm a fan of music.
- Huge fan of music.
- Yeah. I do too. I love it.
- We're very lucky to
get to do this. Thank God
and thank the people.
- Yeah. Yeah. Thank the
fans. Yeah, absolutely.
So how are you deciding which
songs to play this time?
Like how do you decide your set list?
- I don't know yet. - (laughs) I know.
- I don't know yet. You're
going kinda walk and talk
and just be- You like
music. What is your name?
- Tracy. - Hi Ms. Tracy, you like music?
- Oh I love music.
- Really? - Look at those
boots. Hell yes, she does.
- When you say you love
music, what do you love?
- I just love the way it makes me feel.
I always joke- Well my
kids laugh, cause I dance
around the house.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. It's crazy but I
said, "It's just in me,"
you know. You get something
with a good beat and
I just want to dance I can't help it.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Yeah so then that's that part, right.
Do you also like to go
into the toilet with it?
- Well...
- Right. It's like down
like, "Oh my gosh."
- Well... - Okay. I thought
you actually meant like when
I check emails. I was
like, "That's usually where
I check emails." But I
will do this for you.
- No. You know when
you go into the toilet-
- No you go down- you go for
some Jonies, some Alanis.
You go for the sad stuff
too. - There you go.
- Okay. Okay.
- That's what it's supposed to do.
- Yeah especially if I'm sad
that's how I like to connect.
If I'm sad and I feel like I
need to connect to something-
- 100%
- I play something that will make me feel
all the feels, probably cry my face off
and then be good.
- I do- I do love the feels too, you know.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- So if you're doing your
upbeat thing and everything
and you go, "I'm in too good
a mood to even go down there."
All you gotta do is drop the needle on
♪ What do I gotta do to
make you want me ♪ right? ♪
- [Kelly] Oh what a great- Yeah
- Then all of a sudden
you're in the (bleep) right?
(laughter)
- Yes.
- You're like down in this
like, "Oh this feels so good."
(laughter)
and then you come back up and
it's a roller coaster ride.
And that's what I'm hoping
Vegas is going to do.
- It is that. By the way,
that is the experience.
- That perfect.
- I left- I left your show.
I was worn out, emotionally,
cause I had laughed so
hard. I had connected.
It felt like we were in your living room.
I- I sang along. Like
it was such a nostalgic,
amazing experience. That's why I love-
cause you know- you know
what pulls people out now
days you know to go see a show, you know.
Cause you can see it on
YouTube, right? - Right.
- People tape them. So
that's what's cool about you
too, is that it's different every night.
I got that from you too.
I started- I'm changing
mine up for that reason
too. Because you want to
make something special
for like that night,
for those people. But
anyway it's incredible.
And I like dancing too.
My kids think I'm nuts.
I don't care. (laughs) It feels good
to move your body. All
right we need another break.
Don't forget to go online
for tickets to Garth's
Vegas residency, Garth Brooks Plus One.
You're going to love the show.